- [Instructor] We're told
that Flox is a skydiver
on the planet Lernon.
The function. A of w is
equal to 0.2 times W squared,
gives the area, A, in square meters
under Flox's parachute when
it has a width of W meters.
That makes sense.
The function V of A is
equal to the square root
of 980 over A gives Flox's maximum speed
in meters per second when she skydives
with an area of A square
meters under her parachute.
All right.
Write an expression to model
Flox's terminal velocity
when her parachute is W meters wide,
and then they want us to
evaluate the terminal velocity
when her parachute is 14 meters wide.
Well, let's just focus
on the first part first.
Pause the video and see if
you can have a go at that.
All right.
Now let's just think about
what they're asking us.
They want us to model terminal velocity
when her parachute is W meters wide.
So really what they want us to do
is come up with a terminal velocity.
Let's call that V, that
is a function of W,
that is a function of the
width of her parachute.
Well, we have a function here
that gives terminal velocity
as a function of the
area of her parachute,
but lucky for us, we have another function
that gives us area as a function of width.
And so we could say this is
going to be the same thing
as V of this function, right over here.
I'll do it in another color, A of w.
And so that is going to be equal to,
let me keep the colors consistent.
Well, everywhere, where I
see an A in this expression,
I would replace it with A of
W, which is 0.2 W squared.
So it's going to be
equal to the square root
of 980 over instead of
A, I am going to write,
instead of this, I am going
to write 0.2 W squared,
because that is A as a function of W.
0.2 W squared.
So this right over here,
this is an expression
that models Flox's terminal velocity, V,
as a function of the
width of her parachute.
So that's what we have right over there.
And then the next part, they say,
what is Flox's terminal
velocity when her parachute
is 14 meters wide?
Well, then we just have
to say, okay, W is 14.
Let's just evaluate this expression.
So we'll get the square root of 980
over 0.2 times 14 squared.
Well, 14 squared is 196
and this would be equal to the square root
of, see, 980 divided by 196,
I believe is exactly five.
So this would be five divided by 0.2.
And so, five divided by
essentially one fifth
is the same thing as five times five.
So this would be the square root of 25,
which is equal to five.
And the terminal velocity, since we gave
the width in meters,
this is going to give us
the maximum speed in meters per second.
So five meters per second, and we're done.